every neighborhood has a house like it
you can probably picture it that old
decrepit building on the very end of the
street it was there when you moved in
and it'll still be there when you move
out all sorts of salicious rumors spread
about houses like this it's a drug lab
it's a hideout for fugitives it's
haunted but these are all just stories
right some of these houses contain real
nightmares though nightmares like
scp-136
there is a grain of truth in every story
and even lies can reveal certain facts
about their tellers that's why the scp
foundation takes reports of so-called
neighborhood haunted houses seriously
and performs regular checks on such
buildings to see if any of them are
actually the real deal children can have
wild imaginations but when children
living on the same street years apart
with no reason to have been in contact
with one another all start reporting an
eerily similar apparition in that creepy
old house and when the stories go beyond
just getting freaked out and delve into
truly life-altering traumatic paralytic
terror then the foundation really can't
afford not to look into it one otherwise
quiet morning in a sleepy american town
a convoy of fumigation and asbestos
removal trucks pulled in surrounding
that creepy old house at the end of the
street residents were probably thinking
it's about time someone tore that old
death trap down as people in protective
suits spilled into the building these
were of course foundation field agents
who would perform a routine sweep around
every room and fully catalogued the
place it looked like a pretty typical
abandoned house peeling wallpaper dusty
rotten furniture all the trash and
rubble that seems to appear in the
absence of human life the full sweep
took little more than an hour but
towards the end of the observation
period agent sims a field agent posted
in the former child's bedroom began
acting strangely he posed a question
over the team's shared radio frequency
hey can anyone else hear that laughter
confused the other people on the team
responded that no they could not hear
any laughter a few other agents came to
check on the room but they didn't hear
any laughter in there either even though
agent sims appeared visibly
uncomfortable there was no identifiable
source for this discomfort the other
agents left him so they could continue
investigating the rest of the house
other than one agent's fraying nerves
there didn't appear to actually be
anything anomalous about the house then
agent sims screamed and jumped out of
the second story window of the house
sailing down towards the ground and
fracturing his spine on impact what
could have made him do that we're
talking about an scp foundation field
agent here a highly trained individual
hand-picked by the foundation to observe
and track terrifying and potentially
deadly anomalies out in the field what
could he possibly have seen in that
decrepit old house that would lead him
to believe leaping to his death was a
preferable alternative to facing it this
was a question that the foundation
absolutely had to get an answer to they
intensified their search on the child's
bedroom as the body of agent sims was
carted away that's when they found the
object that they would later deem as
scp-132
a little ragdoll made of old cloth the
kind of thing you could easily imagine
getting carted around by some ragamuffin
child at the turn of the last century
this was the only object of interest in
the entire room so it was tagged bagged
and taken back to the nearest foundation
containment facility for further testing
they had no idea what they were about to
unleash when the doll was first brought
into its containment chamber one
particular scientist on the research
team dr meyers a headstrong young
researcher freshly farmed from a
prestigious university took a morbid
interest in the doll something about it
even in the absence of readily apparent
anomalous effects made her feel oddly
uncomfortable the doll seemed to carry a
vague aura of doom was this what made
agent sims act the way he had or was
this only the beginning a d-class was
brought in for the first wave of testing
the unfortunate former arsonist was
forced to simply stand around in the
room with a doll and wait until
something interesting happened and for
20 minutes no anomalous activity was
reported then the d-class began
frantically looking around the room like
a frightened animal dr meyers who had
been observing the test radioed in and
asked what was happening it's this
laughter this weird freaky laughter like
some crazy lady is in here i can't see
her though can any of you see her can
any of you hear that they couldn't see
or hear anything according to all their
monitors it was just a lonely d-class
standing around in an otherwise empty
room with nothing but a rag doll five
minutes after the d-class reported
hearing the eerie laughter he collapsed
to the ground shrieking like a maniac
and crawling away from something he
could not see he was emitting the
desperate screams of a man who truly
believed something was about to take his
life but nothing was there he backed
into the corner of the room jibbering
incoherently and scratching desperately
at the wall until his fingernails were
ripping off leaving bloody traces behind
in the end a pair of guards entered the
chamber and had to drag him out the
d-class had urinated in fear and seemed
to have temporarily lost the use of his
legs from sheer panic he was out of
commission for several hours afterwards
breaking into on and off screaming fits
whenever someone approached him upon
reviewing the footage of the experiment
dr meyers noticed something strange the
moment that the d-class had begun
screaming the doll had disappeared from
the room it only re-materialized in its
previous position when the d-class was
finally dragged from the room
eventually the d-class became lucid
enough to be properly interviewed about
his experience he said that after first
hearing the laughter a sense of
overpowering dread had begun building
within him five minutes later that was
when the entity later dubbed scp-136-2
first appeared the vision that appeared
to him could generously be described as
human but it was a little too tall to
really qualify the monster appeared to
be female but like a freakish carnival
house of mirrors exaggeration of what
one thinks of being female long flowing
hair large breasts and a barbie doll
thin waist she looked like the
nightmarish doodle of a hormonal teen
boy come to life with a face twisted
into a rictus grim somewhere between
arousal and agony showing way too many
teeth the creature was nude and posed
provocatively but it was anything but
appealing the d-class reported that just
seeing it was the most frightening
experience of his life and then it
started moving it was slowly floating
through the air towards him like a
vengeful ghost that painful smile
getting wider as it drew closer to him
the d-class could only describe the
whole experience as feeling like death
itself was coming towards him when the
creature was finally looming over him as
he cowered in the corner it opened its
toothline jaws and let out a long
piercing shriek before disappearing in
the following weeks the d-class was kept
for testing he experienced severe night
terrors every single night afterwards
all of them related to scp-136
further tests looked into the doll
itself but there didn't seem to be
anything anomalous about its
construction it appeared to be made from
the kind of plain non-anomalous
materials you'd expect from any doll of
this variety though occasionally the
exact materials would change even
between observers in addition to the
most common cloth variety witnesses have
reported the doll being made of clay
wood and metal with 10 viewing the doll
as male with the rest all agreeing that
the doll is female the foundation
conducted a battery of tests on the doll
just to make sure that the results were
largely consistent across all subjects
over 25 subjects were tested on scp-136
all reporting roughly the same results
laughter after 20 minutes of observation
a few minutes of silence and then
according to subject testimonials the
appearance of the same grinning naked
apparition inducing a state of truly
primal terror in its victims
interestingly not all of the subjects
were d-classes some were volunteering
scientists who were aware of the
potential effects but let their morbid
curiosity get the better of them
thinking they would be prepared to face
whatever terrifying vision would
manifest from the doll but in every case
they were reduced to the same screaming
traumatized wrecks but when a foundation
researcher named dr simon the 25th
subject of the scp-136 experiments
volunteered for testing things took an
even more horrifying turn
during the testing period dr simon had
the unusual experience of not actually
seeing the
scp-136-2 entity after being told how
terrifying it was by co-workers he was a
little disappointed that he didn't get
to share their fears later that day he
went to get himself a warm cup of coffee
from the science employee break room his
co-workers became concerned when his
coffee mug dropped to the ground and
shattered as dr simon pointed into a
nearby empty hallway and began screaming
he claimed that he could see her
floating down the hallway towards him
her face twisted into that menacing grin
as none of the other scientists could
see what simon was seeing they
surrounded him and attempted to calm him
assuming that he was perhaps the victim
of some kind of sudden psychotic break
but minutes later every scientist in the
break room collapsed and fell
unconscious not long after they all
began to wake up except dr simon he had
fallen into a coma and died while still
on life support three days later it was
the first report of scp-136 causing a
death since agent sim's unfortunate fall
dr meyers immediately requested that
scp-136 be reclassified from euclid to
keter class so more resources could be
allotted for its containment
administration denied any changes to the
containment procedures of scp-136
frustrating dr meyers but little did she
know that it was because site
administration had ulterior motives for
scp-136
no matter who they were whether they
were the hardened killers of d-class the
trained soldiers of the foundation field
agent core or jaded scientists who had
seen any number of horrors each week as
part of their normal jobs
scp-136 had the unique ability to reduce
its victims to terrifying wrecks in a
move that feels decidedly more in line
with the chaos insurgency side
administration had started using scp-136
to assist in enhanced interrogation with
detained people of interest even the
toughest nuts to crack soon became very
talkative after the appearance of
scp-136-2
traumatized them for life essentially
the administrators were making a kind of
deal with the devil allowing scp-136
more free reign in exchange for them
gathering valuable intel from these
victims but as always the problem with
making deals with the devil is that the
devil is always going to collect his due
in the end dr meyer's warnings would
continue to fall upon deaf ears though
even as the creature's power seemed to
grow tests on d-class continued with the
entity traumatizing a whole group at
once during one of these experiments
however when dr meyers herself along
with a few agents entered the testing
chamber to drag out their twitching
bodies they all fell unconscious when dr
meyers woke back up three of the
d-classes had fallen into comas like dr
simon and died shortly after dr meyers
pleaded with the administration to
terminate the doll but her requests were
denied it was proving to be too valuable
in its various interrogations and
besides nobody was sure if the doll
could even be terminated whenever it was
damaged it simply disappeared and
reappeared within a 1 meter radius the
only thing that hadn't been tried was
full vaporization which dr meyer
superiors refused to sign off on
scp-136 was here to stay unfortunately
the same could not be said for dr meyers
herself after one more unfortunate
testing incident where d-class
disappeared entirely in what seemed to
be clear evidence of
scp-136's growing power dr meyers
implored site administration to
reclassify the anomaly and slate it for
termination it was getting more powerful
more unstable and more dangerous but
rather than terminate the anomalous
ragdoll in the end all they did was
remove dr meyers from the
scp-136 case with her gone there was one
less thing for them to worry about as
they gave more and more victims to
scp-136
using its dark powers to torture
detained people of interest into telling
them everything they wanted to know but
with the entity seeming to grow more
powerful with every victim it seems very
likely that dr meyer's worst fears will
come true and one day those controlling
the terrifying anomaly will find that
they're the ones hearing a strange evil
laughter coming from nowhere at all now
check out scp-610
the flesh that hates and
scp-1337 the hitchhiker for more scps
that'll chill you to the core